- Kids, don't try this at home.
(heroic music)
- Let's go.
(squeals)
(balloon squeaking)
- You don't get in the Superbowl
by not being in 10th.
- I'm gonna take a note from Isaac
and start building while I drink.
- What are you doing?
- Making mistakes, man.
- They asked Picasso what he was doing.
- Get outta my balloon idea!
- You're just building a wizard's staff
with a balloon that's losing air.
(balloon pops)
(screams and laughter)
- You guys get outta here.
- That's so good!
I mean it sucks mine's way better.
(laughter)
I'm double tasking.
- You're double tasking?
Is that what it's called?
Double tasking?
(balloon pops)
- Oh, yes!
(cheering)
That baby is what we call payback!
- How much time do we have left?
- You guys are a mess and
I'm fucking cleaning up.
- 90 seconds?
Give me another balloon!
- Nooooooooo!
- Oh my God I can't believe
I pulled it out in the end.
(grumbling)
How's that cowboy?
Like my burps?
- Oh man, I can smell your burps.
- What's wrong?
- I had the best thing going.
- You really did.
- I'm a Goddamned fiend.
- Ok you know what this looks like
a fucking mountain.
(people counting down from 10)
Noo boooo!
Sorry I booed you, it's not your fault.
- Yes!
(screaming)
- Oh baby!
- I had the most amazing trophy,
of all time I'm pretty sure.
Except it popped
because I got too aggressive
and tried to put hair on it.
I don't know, I'm okay with finishing
four in the 15 minutes.
Proud of it.
My parents won't be proud, but I'm proud.
I made this nice cowboy
and I was gonna make him
a nice mountain to stand on.
I only finished two and a half beers
and I'm like this, so that's...
- I was really stoked,
these guys went straight for the beer,
I had a strategy, I was gonna
blow my balloon up first.
The first one kind of ran away from me
the second one popped.
I was really proud of this one,
this third one was gonna be nice.
It was gonna be the good one.
- What does it say?
- Nice.
- And I like that my failures
are just jokes to you,
you bastards.
- I feel like I wanna budge your trophies.
Here they're all around me.